Information over-consumption is what a lot
of people think they mean when they say information
overload.
Information over-consumption makes a lot
more sense.
We don’t say that someone is suffering
from food overload.
It’s not like fried chickens are offing
themselves then jumping into deep fryers and
some undead zombie chicken flies out of the
deep fryer and into our mouths for us to eat.
That never—that hasn’t happened to my
knowledge and if it does, well, then we’re
in the middle of the chicken apocalypse and
that’s problematic.
. . . Sometimes I laugh at my own jokes.
. . . But information over-consumption is
really the right frame for us to look at things
through.
We have to take responsibility both for
the supply and the demand of information and
our role as a consumer and a supplier of this
stuff.
In the world of food, for instance, we have
industrialized agriculture, and as we industrialized
agriculture we created large corporations
who have fiduciary responsibility to produce
cheap and popular calories, and what that
means is that they go, “Well, what is it
that people want?”
And now we’ve made it so that you can
have a pizza with everything on it delivered
to your house for $15 in a half hour made
from all kinds of different things from all
kinds of different places.
This is as much of a feat of science in
my mind as putting a man on the moon, if you
really sort of think about what it takes in
order to do that.
And I think that same thing has gone on with
information.
We’ve industrialized media, and our media
companies now have a fiduciary responsibility
to produce cheap and popular information,
and that’s led us down the road of Glenn
Beck and Sarah Palin and Keith Olbermann and
Rachel Maddow, who don’t really want to
inform us.
They want to affirm us.
They want to tell us what it is that we
want.
I mean think about this for a second.
Who wants to hear the truth when they can
hear that they’re right?
I certainly don’t.
I love being affirmed.
I love being told that I'm right, and I
certainly like that a lot more than I like
being informed.
And I think that’s important to realize
when we talk about this supply and demand
problem of blaming the victim is that we’re
wired for what was good for us and not necessarily
what is good for us, and our producers are
producing what was good for us, but not necessarily
what is good for us, so I don’t want to
blame the victim, but I do want us to start
waking up and realizing that this has a—we
have to have a conscious level of consumption
when it comes to our information intake.
Your information diet is an ethical choice
of yours, so when you’re on the Huffington
Postlooking at, say, the Kardashians and you
click on the Kardashians, understand that
you are not only reading that article, but
you’re also voting for that article.
You’re telling an editor to produce more
content like that at the expense of the stuff
that you didn’t click on, and so we have
this sort of rapidization of the tyranny of
the majority, if you will, because of that
because we are constantly being given what
it is that we want, not necessarily what it
is that we need, and I think that’s vital
to understand, that there is a difference
between those two things.
But in the world of food if we are only
given what we want, what would we look like?
We’d be—well we’d look like, kind
of like what we do today.
We’re about 35% of Americans are obese
and I think that same thing is going on with
information.
I don’t want people to really focus on consuming
less, just like I think appropriate nutrition
shouldn’t be focused on consuming less.
It should be about consuming well and being
healthy about your information consumption,
and that’s where I’d like to see us go.
That’s what I’d like to see us do.
That’s what I’d like to see us do is
to start building healthy frameworks for information
consumption, and sometimes that means reducing
it, sometimes that means subtracting some
of the bad stuff and adding some of the good
stuff.